Kourtney Kardashian celebrated her 40th
birthday bash in a truly epic way on
Thursday night wait Kourtney's 40 where
does the time go
the party was just as glitzy as you'd
imagine with Robin Thicke serenading the
birthday girl even SIA joined in and
there were all sorts of personalized
touches that included some infamous
keeping up with the Kardashian quotes
like these napkins and this tequila
bottle she's the least exciting to look
at I mean you have to admit that's
pretty good inside Scott Disick showed
up as did Courtney's one-time ruurd
fling Lucas Abbas there's just too much
going on Kim also hung with former BFF
Paris Hilton as did Khloe and Kendall
Kylie dance the night away with mom Kris
and can we talk about this cake okay
we're just hoping everyone followed
courts very specific party rules
Courtney has a lot of rules and there
I'm on the stone evil on a thread what
are the rules of your birthday parties
Courtney what are they oh my god it Oh
speeches no speeches uh-huh mom is he
not allowed to cry if my mom cries I
have two son house that all doubt if she
cries shuttle my mom out one can only
hope to throw a birthday party like that
though am i right to make sure you are
always keeping up with the kardashians
make sure you're subscribed to all
things et until next time I'm Katie
Krauss and bye for now